you hopefully have a little intuition
now on what a double integral is or how
we go about figuring out the volume
under surface so let's actually compute
it I think it'll all become a lot more
concrete so let's say I have the surface
Z and it's a function of x and y and it
equals X Y squared the surface in
three-dimensional space and I want to
know the volume between this surface and
the xy-plane and the domain in the
xy-plane that I care about is X is
greater than or equal to zero and less
than or equal to 2 and Y is greater than
or equal to zero and less than or equal
to 1 and let's see what that looks like
just so we have a good visualization of
it so I graphed it here and we can
rotate around this is Z equals XY
squared and this is the bounding box
right X goes from 0 to 2 Y goes from 0
to 1 so we literally want this you can
almost view at the volume well not
almost exactly view it is the volume
under this surface between this surface
the top surface and the xy-plane and
I'll rotate it around so you can get a
little bit better sense of the actual
volume let me rotate it now I should use
the mouse for this
so it's this space underneath here you
could it's got like a it's like a
makeshift shelter or something and I
could rotate it a little bit so you can
see whatever is under this between the
two surfaces that's the volume whoops
I've flipped it there you go
so that's the volume that we care about
let's figure out how to do it and we'll
try to gather a little bit of the
intuition as we go along so I'm going to
draw a not as impressive version of that
graph but I think it'll it'll do the job
for now let me draw my axes that's my
x-axis
that's my y-axis that's my z-axis
X Y Z and we're going X is going from
zero to two let's say that's 2 y is
going from 0 to 1 and we're taking so
we're taking the volume above this
rectangle and the xy-plane and then the
surface I'm going to try my best to draw
I'll draw it in a different color I'm
looking at the picture at this end it
looks something like this it looks
something like this and then it has a
straight line see if I can draw this
surface going down like that and then if
I was really good I could shade it it
looks something like this
or shade it the surface looks something
like that
and this right here is above this right
like this is the the top the bottom left
corner you can almost view it so this is
let me say the yellow is the top of the
surface that's the top of the surface
and then this is under the surface right
so we care about this volume underneath
here let me draw the let me show you
what the actual surface of this volume
underneath here alright I think you get
the idea so how do we do that well in
the last in the last example we said
well let's pick an arbitrary Y and for
that Y let's figure out the area under
the curve so if we if we fix some Y if
we fix some one when you actually do the
problem you have to think of it think
about it in this much detail but I want
to give you the intuition so if we pick
just an arbitrary Y here so on that Y we
could think of it if we have a fixed Y
then the function of x and y you can
almost view it as a as a a function of
just X for that given Y and so we're
kind of figuring out the value of this
of the area under this curve right you
could this should you should view this
as kind of an up-down curve for a given
Y so if we know Y we can we can figure
out then
for example if Y was fine
this function would become Z equals 25 X
right and then that's easy to figure out
the the value of the curve under so
we'll make the value under the curve as
a function of Y we'll pretend like it's
just a constant so let's do that
so if we have a DX that's our change in
X and then our height of each of our
rectangles it's going to be a function
it's going to be Z the height is Z which
is a function of x and y so we can take
the integral so the area of each of
these is going to be our function XY
squared I'll do it here because I'll run
out of space X Y squared times the width
which is DX and if we want the area of
this slice for given Y we just integrate
along the x-axis right we're going to
integrate from X is equal to 0 to X is
equal to 2 from X is equal to 0 to 2
fair enough now but we don't still want
to figure out the area under under the
curve at one slice for one particular Y
we want to figure out the entire area of
the curve so what we do is we say okay
find the area under of this under the
curve not the surface under this curve
for a particular Y is this expression
well what if I gave it a little bit of
depth right if I multiplied this area
times dy then it would give me a little
bit of depth right we kind of have a
three-dimensional slice of the volume
that we care about I know it's hard to
imagine let me bring that here so if I
had a slice here this is what we just
figured out the area of us of a slice
and then I'm multiplying it by dy to
give it a little bit of depth so you
multiply it by dy to give it a little
bit of depth and then if we want the
entire volume under the curve we add all
the dys together take the infinite sum
of these infinitely small volumes really
now and so we will integrate from Y is
equal to 0 to Y is equal to 1 I know
this graph is a little hard to
understand but you might want to
re-watch the other the first video I
the easier to understand surface so now
how do we evaluate this well like we
said that we you evaluate from the
inside and go outward and it's almost
like taking its it's taking like a
partial derivative in Reverse so we're
taking the we're integrating here with
respect to X so we can treat Y just like
a constant like it's like the number
five or something like that so it really
doesn't change the integral so what's
the antiderivative of XY squared well
the antiderivative of XY squared I want
to make sure I'm color consistent well
the antiderivative of X is X to the
one-half sorry x squared over two x
squared over 2 and then Y squared is
just a constant right and then we don't
have to worry about plus C since this is
a definite integral and we're going to
evaluate that at two and zero and then
we still have the outside integral with
respect to Y so once we figure that out
we're going to integrate it from zero to
1 with respect to dy now what does this
evaluate we take we put a two in here if
you put a two in there you get two
squared over two two squared over two
well that's just 4 over 2 so it's 2 y
squared - y squared
- is 0 squared over 2 times y squared
well that's just going to be 0 so it's
minus 0 I won't write that down because
hopefully that's a little bit of second
nature to you we just evaluated this the
two endpoints and I'm short for space so
this evaluated a 2y squared and now we
evaluate the outside integral 0 1 dy
this is an important thing to realize
when we evaluated this inside integral
remember what we were doing we were
trying to figure out for given Y what
the area of this surface was well not
this surface the area under the the
surface on this kind of for given Y
right for given Y that surface kind of
turns into a curve and we've tried to
figure out the area under that curve in
the traditional sense right so this is
going to be a funk this ended up being a
function of Y and that makes sense
because depending on which y we pick
we're going to get a different air
here because because obviously depending
on which why we pick the area kind of a
wall drop straight down that area is
going to change so we've got a function
of why when we evaluated this and now we
just have integrate with respect to Y
and this is just plain old vanilla
definite integration what's the
antiderivative of 2y squared well that
equals 2 times y to the third over 3 or
2/3 Y to the third we're evaluate that
at 1 and 0 which is equal to let's see
y1 to the third times 2/3 s 2/3 minus 0
two-thirds times two-thirds well that's
just 0 so it equals 2/3 2/3 if these
were if our units were meters it would
be 2/3 meters cubed or cubic meters but
there you go that's how you evaluate a
double integral there really isn't a new
skill here you just have to make sure to
keep track of the variables treat them
constant when they need to be treated
constant and then treat them as a
variable of integration when it's
appropriate anyway I will see you in the
next video